[Music]
ever miss it I haven't touched a gun in
10 years after what happened that night
I just put my sword down you know
without that bad luck you're gonna be
okay
I never would have met Sara I never
would have my kids daddy loves ooh yeah
that loves it
love it you matter mr. Sawyer you will
the very first family we've had in the
residential section of the pole after
you secure the assessment when you think
of the building the Pearl is the most
advanced super tall structure in the
world it's a breathtaking achievement
but no one really knows what would
happen if things go wrong hello boys
I did burn the 96 floors on fire zero
listen to me
the fire is not gonna stop keep going up
don't stop don't look back get back
whoa whoa whoa whoa you don't understand
my family's in there
don't doubt that was tough
jumped off a supercrime just Amanda was
[ __ ] fault this booty is protecting
something that I want
you're going to get it for me anything
can be done at the proper motivation No
[Music]
we got to do this guy
it's okay to be scared
in order to be brave you gotta be a
little scared I gotta gets out of this
building and I need you to be brave
right now yeah
dad loves it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]